on the Great Plains just east of the
Rocky Mountains lies one of America's
most closely guarded secrets scattered
along an unremarkable road the u.s.
keeps some of its most powerful weapons
we've been granted rare access to the
frontline of the nation's nuclear
deterrence to step inside a bunker that
has the capability to launch nuclear war
I be your escort official during your
visit to the missile burn facility
do you understand your responsibilities
while hundreds working
[Music]
behind these gates in Nebraska a men and
women hold the world's fate in their
fingertips we have a rapidly emerging
crisis that requires the use of ICBMs we
can respond to the president's direction
in minutes the country now has 400 ICBMs
or intercontinental ballistic missiles
each is much more powerful than the bomb
dropped on Hiroshima security is tight
at what feels like the entrance to
another universe we're about to go more
than 70 feet underground to the launch
control center where men and women known
as missile ears are on alert 24 hours a
day
[Music]
and test lamp push-button press if
Donald Trump orders a strike Air Force
officers Crowley and Bryant can launch
warheads within minutes
typically a day-to-day we are
responsible of 10 nuclear warheads
that's enormous
pretty tired [ __ ] definitely a
enormous amount of power but we take the
responsibility seriously to the point
where we're always training and we're
always innovating they are rigorously
and regularly assess taking part in
daily drills for an event that will
likely never come I mean how can you be
passionate about fitting underground for
24 hours at a time it's kind of like
camping on an airplane but you become so
invested in the mission and the people
that you you love what you do I think
that's what surprised me the most and
one times comes to launch this command
center was built in the 1960s but the
threat is evolving a missile from Fe
Warren was recently taxed launched from
Vandenberg Air Force Base in California
back at base Colonel Matthew Dillo
insists it's not a knee-jerk response to
provocations from North Korea
this isn't saber rattling by the United
States this is a very deliberate number
of operational tests that we do that are
pre-planned and and scheduled over the
course of the year but will the new
commander-in-chief taken the attack what
I've seen through several
administrations is that no matter what
political affiliation the president has
when they see sort of the underlying
security conundrum that they're faced
with they may argue about what the
posture is and what the force structure
mix is and how much investment to have
in that but they all reach the same
underlying a conclusion is that the
nuclear deterrent force is absolutely
critical to national security
the colonel described this as a
rolls-royce that's had a lot of mileage
Americans foes know where it's parked
but it's still seen as something they
can't afford to close the door
hadiyyah-lah
Sky News Nebraska